.
1 Mio. Menschen müssen jedes Jahr
in der Schweiz ins Spital.
Für sie zählt nur die Gesundheit.
Ich denke an meine Tochter.
Ich denke an liebe Leute
und dass das gut wird und ich
nicht mehr so viele Schmerzen habe
und nicht mehr so leiden muss.
Wir haben etwas für die Kinder:
Das ist unser Rettungsbärchen.
Für Spitäler
ist Gesundheit auch ein Geschäft.
Sie müssen um Patienten buhlen.
Setzt mir der Chirurg
eine neue Hüfte ein,
spüre ich
eine schiefe Schraube nicht.
Aber eigentlich ist das
das Wichtigste.
Aber ich kann beurteilen,
dass Service, Umgang, Kaffee,
Essen und Zimmer super sind.
Darum setzen Spitäler
zunehmend auf Marketing.
Dann hat man lieber Parkett,
das nicht so lange hält -
aber man ist attraktiv,
hat Patienten und Geld.
Verdrängt Marketing
die medizinische Qualität?
Wir begleiten Patienten
und Patientinnen
und schildern ihre Schicksale.
Wären die vorhergegangenen
Operationen korrekt verlaufen,
wäre der Leidensweg
sicher viel kürzer gewesen.
In der Schweiz können Patientinnen
und Patienten das Spital wählen
und so
eine bessere Behandlung bekommen.
Es gibt Unterschiede
zwischen den Spitälern.
Diese Unterschiede sind statistisch
feststellbar und nachweisbar.
Ich finde, diesen Mehrwert
sollten die Patienten kennen.
Die Spitäler stehen im Wettbewerb.
Was kostet das? Und wer profitiert?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Helle glockige Klänge *
Das ist mein Kraftort.
Jetzt zünde ich speziell Kerzen an,
damit die Operation gut verläuft.
Für den Chirurgen,
das Operationsteam.
Eine für meinen Mann,
damit es ihm gutgeht,
wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin -
und eine für mich.
* Helle glockige Klänge *
Vor der Operation
habe ich keine Angst.
Ja, ja.
Das kommt gut.
Antoinette Huser ist 75-jährig.
Sie will ein neues Hüftgelenk.
Dort vorne
bin ich als Lektorin tätig.
Und der Gang dorthin ...
... ist immer beschwerlich.
Ich reisse mich immer sehr zusammen.
Dann verkrampfe ich mich
allerdings noch mehr.
Und jetzt hoffe ich,
dass ich das alles
wieder super machen kann.
* Helle glockige Klänge *
Eine Kniebeuge kann ich
auch nicht mehr richtig machen,
da bin ich auch eingeschränkt.
Aber das wird wieder.
Dazu muss ich nachher turnen.
* Die Kirchturmuhr schlägt. *
Hüftoperationen
gelten als Routineeingriff.
Wenn alles gut läuft, ist man
nach wenigen Monaten wieder fit.
* Sanfte Musik *
Doch jeder Eingriff birgt ein Risiko.
Immer wieder
gehen Operationen schief,
wie bei der 61-jährigen
Jeannette Petrusch.
Bei ihr führte das zu grossem Leid.
Seit Jahren hat sie Schmerzen.
Man sagte mir,
Hüftoperationen seien heute
keine grosse Sache mehr.
Aufgrund dessen befand ich, dass es
okay sei und gut werden würde.
Und dann ist das Ganze
einfach nicht gut geworden.
Er hat nichts ausgemessen.
Er hat einfach was eingesetzt,
sag ich mal.
Das Gelenk war zu kurz,
die Pfanne war zu klein.
Die Kugel passte nicht richtig.
Man geht zum Arzt
und dann kommt alles gut - denkt man.
Doch häufig stimmt das nicht.
Eine missglückte Hüftoperation
hat Jeannette Petruschs Leben
auf den Kopf gestellt.
Ihre Geschichte ist eine Geschichte
von Komplikationen,
Infektionen und kaputten Prothesen.
Jeannette Petrusch
steht stellvertretend für Menschen,
die nach einem Spitalaufenthalt
mit Problemen kämpfen.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich
eine Zeit lang recht deprimiert war.
Es ging einfach nicht mehr.
Ich konnte nicht mehr Sport treiben.
Ich konnte nicht mehr ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Ich hatte Beschwerden,
weil ich gern tanzen ging.
Auch dort hatte ich Schmerzen.
Und ...
Sportmässig:
Mit Skifahren musste ich aufhören.
Schlittschuhlaufen
ging überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das Einzige, was im Sport noch geht,
was ich auch noch mache -
seit einem Jahr
zwar auch nicht mehr -,
ist Velo fahren.
Das geht auch nicht mehr.
* Nachdenkliche Streicherklänge *
Ich bin ein Mensch,
der wieder mobil sein möchte.
Ich möchte nicht
auf fremde Hilfe angewiesen sein
und möchte alles
sehr selbstständig machen.
Es knackt und knarrt immer
in dieser Hüfte,
und sie schmerzt ziemlich.
Jeannette Petrusch
will endlich eine stabile Hüfte
und ohne Schmerzen leben.
Dafür nimmt sie zwei neue,
aufwendige Operationen auf sich.
Ich bin froh, wenn die Operation
endlich stattfindet.
Wie sicher sind unsere Spitäler?
Bei wie vielen Menschen
geht alles gut?
geht etwas schief?
Man kann davon ausgehen,
dass etwa 10 % der Patienten,
die ins Spital eintreten,
ein unerwünschtes Ereignis erleiden.
Etwa die Hälfte davon
gilt als vermeidbar.
Das sind 5-8 %.
Wenn man bedenkt, wie viele Tausend
Menschen jährlich ins Spital müssen,
dann ist das eine hohe Zahl
von Menschen, die betroffen sind
von solchen vermeidbaren
unerwünschten Ereignissen.
David Schwappach
forscht an der Universität Bern
zur Qualität und Sicherheit
der Schweizer Spitäler.
Er sieht Mängel im System.
Wie sind Qualität und Sicherheit
im Schweizer Gesundheitssystem?
Ehrlich gesagt:
Wir wissen das oft nicht so genau.
Ein Merkmal des Systems ist,
dass wir sehr wenig Daten haben.
Zu den Daten, die wir haben,
muss man sagen:
Da liegt die Schweiz im Durchschnitt
anderer vergleichbarer Länder.
Im Mittelfeld - könnte man sagen.
Und dieses Mittelfeld
ist eigentlich nicht gut genug.
Beromünster im Kanton Luzern.
Ein Tag noch bis zur Hüftoperation
von Antoinette Huser.
Jetzt geht es los.
Es geht los.
- (Lachend) Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich bin etwas nervös,
aber das gehört dazu.
Es ist halt schon ein Eingriff.
Ich bin aber eher nervös,
ob zu Hause alles klappen wird.
Wieso?
Ich war noch nie drei Wochen weg:
jetzt ins Spital
und dann noch in die Reha.
In der Schweiz gilt das Prinzip
der freien Spitalwahl.
Antoinette Huser hat nicht
das naheliegendste gewählt,
sondern das Kantonsspital Nidwalden.
Ihr Mann fährt sie hin, knapp 40 Min.
Es sind gemischte Gefühle.
Wir waren in dem Sinn
nie länger als eine Woche getrennt.
Wir haben immer zusammengewohnt -
seit 50 Jahren.
In welchem Spital
man sich behandeln lässt,
kann einen grossen Unterschied
machen.
(Frau, am Telefon)
... dass ich das ausfüllen kann.
Matthias Steiner
von der Krankenkasse Concordia
berät Patientinnen und Patienten,
bevor diese sich operieren lassen.
Ja, genau.
- Ja.
Wie sieht es mit Physiotherapie
oder anderweitiger Therapie aus?
Die Krankenkassen
fördern den Wettkampf der Spitäler -
auch aus Eigeninteresse.
Sie wollen tiefe Kosten
und teure Komplikationen vermeiden.
Matthias Steiner hat eine
Vergleichssoftware mitentwickelt,
die sich auf öffentlich
verfügbare Qualitätsdaten stützt.
Das sind z.B. Fallzahlen
für eine Diagnose.
Das ist die Patientenzufriedenheit
pro Spital.
Das ist die Infektions-
und Sterblichkeitsrate.
Wir von der Concordia haben
zusätzlich die Aufenthaltsdauer
und die Kosten in der Grund-
und Zusatzversicherung verwendet.
Antoinette Huser
wohnt in Beromünster im Kanton Luzern
und wählte
das Kantonsspital Nidwalden in Stans.
Luftlinie: rund 30 km.
In diesem Umkreis
gibt es rund 30 Spitäler,
die Hüftoperationen anbieten.
Dank der freien Spitalwahl
kann man in alle gehen,
meist sogar ohne Zusatzversicherung.
Z.B. in das Zentrumsspital in Luzern,
aber auch in die grossen Spitäler
von Zürich
sowie in renommierte
orthopädische Privatkliniken.
Sind alle gleich gut?
Matthias Steiner hat die Spitäler
mit seinem Programm verglichen
und mit einem Ampelsystem bewertet.
Auch im Internet
finden sich Spitalvergleiche,
meist aber ohne Beratung
und nicht alle gleich fundiert.
Doch nutzen die Versicherten
diese Möglichkeit zur Spitalwahl?
Sie wird genutzt, aber zu wenig.
Vielfach ist die Empfehlung
für einen Spitaleintritt:
"Das näheste - oder ich habe
schon viele dort zugewiesen."
Wir haben eine gewisse Datenlage,
die der Haus- oder Spezialarzt
nicht hat.
Es ist ein zusätzliches Kriterium
für eine
gute Entscheidungsgrundlage.
Antoinette Huser
hat die freie Spitalwahl genutzt
und lässt sich in Stans operieren.
Dort steht die Bewertungsampel
auf Grün.
Aber das wusste sie nicht.
Bei ihr war ein Inserat
ausschlaggebend.
Dort warb das Spital für
einen Vortrag über Hüftoperationen.
Sie ging hin und war beeindruckt.
Ich habe mich überzeugen lassen,
dass es richtig ist,
dass ich es dort mache.
Ich dachte nie,
dass ich in ein Kantonsspital gehe,
aber mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir,
dass es richtig ist.
Würde man immer
auf Statistiken etc. schauen ...
Es kann überall etwas geschehen.
- Natürlich.- Ja, oder?
Es gibt Qualitätskriterien
und Statistiken,
die bei der Spitalwahl
helfen könnten.
Doch diese sind für Laien schwer
zugänglich und oft kaum verständlich.
Wie Antoinette Huser
verlassen sich viele Menschen
nicht gerne auf Zahlen.
Oh, ich muss zuerst
die Füsse aufsetzen. Au.
Nur ruhig nehmen, ruhig nehmen.
Da drüben ist der Bürgenstock.
- Ich muss erst etwas gerade stehen.
* Sie atmet tief aus. *
Antoinette Huser
ist halbprivat versichert.
Sie erhält ein Einzelzimmer.
So, vielen Dank.
- Sehr gern.
Oh, es ist gut.
- Ja, schön.
Doch, doch.
Hey, schau mal!
- Die Bergspitze ist ...
... im Nebel.
Anfang Februar 2020.
Die letzte Mahlzeit vor der
Operation am nächsten Morgen.
Vielen Dank.
- Ravioli.
Und Suppe.
- Das ist super, vielen Dank.
Guten Appetit.- Danke.
- Bitte.- Vielen Dank.
Das sieht gut aus.
Patientinnen und Patienten
brauchen nicht nur Medizin.
Sie wollen sich auch wohlfühlen, was
das Kantonsspital Nidwalden erkannte.
Mmh, lecker.
Sehr gut.
Ich bräuchte
überhaupt keinen Hotelservice.
Mit der Hotellerie
ist es heute schon ein Luxus.
Aber ich kann das nicht ändern.
Und natürlich bin ich froh,
dass ich so gut betreut werde.
Ist ein solcher Service
wirklich nötig?
Oder geht das Spital in Stans
mit Komfort und Luxus auf Kundenfang?
Ein Spital
hat keine Daseinsberechtigung,
wenn Operation und Pflege
nicht gut sind.
Das ist vorausgesetzt. Ohne Funda-
ment kann kein Haus gebaut werden.
Das nützt heute nichts mehr,
das ist zu wenig.
Heute haben wir die Marktwirtschaft,
die freie Spitalwahl.
Sind Kommunikation,
Infrastruktur, Hotellerie
und Dienstleistungsverständnis
besser ...
Das ist grotesk,
das ist leider so.
Der Patient
kann das besser beurteilen.
Setzt mir der Chirurg
eine neue Hüfte ein,
spüre ich eine schiefe Schraube
nicht.
Aber eigentlich ist das
das Wichtigste.
Aber ich kann beurteilen,
dass Service, Umgang, Kaffee,
Essen und Zimmer super sind.
Darum haben die Privatspitäler
die Analyse früher gemacht,
was der Patient beurteilen kann.
Dort waren sie voraus -
wir haben jetzt aufgeholt.
Was im Privatspital gut und wichtig
ist, haben wir auch übernommen.
Der Ingenieur und Ökonom
wurde 2019 zum Spitaldirektor
des Jahres gewählt.
Patientinnen und Patienten
sind auch Kunden.
Das Credo von Urs Baumberger.
Wir verkaufen hier lokale Produkte.
Es soll auch für den Patienten,
der evtl. mit den Stöcken
spazieren geht, kurzweilig sein.
Wir sehen die Eingangshalle.
Mir ist wichtig, im ganzen Haus
eine Architektur zu haben,
die die Genesungsprozesse
unterstützt.
Damit haben wir
vor zehn Jahren angefangen.
Helles Holz
sorgt für ein Wohlfühl-Ambiente.
Aber auch die Akustik:
die schallschluckende Decke,
aber auch das Licht, der Geruch.
Patienten, Besucher und Mit-
arbeitende sollen sich wohlfühlen.
Schön sieht es aus
im Spital Nidwalden.
Aber: Braucht ein Spital
wirklich einen teuren Parkettboden?
Klar hält dieser Parkettboden
vielleicht ein paar Jahre weniger
als ein Linoleumboden.
Es nützt mir nichts,
20 Jahre Linoleum zu haben,
aber nach fünf Jahren
bin ich nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig
und habe keine Patienten mehr.
Dann nützt mir der Linoleumboden
nichts, da habe ich lieber Parkett.
Er hält weniger lang, aber ich bin
attraktiv, habe Patienten und Geld.
Selbst in der CT-Röhre soll sich
niemand wie im Spital fühlen.
Naturfilme
sorgen für ein entspanntes Ambiente.
Lohnt sich so ein Bildschirm?
Das kostet alles.
Der Bildschirm kostet ca. 2'000 Fr.,
3'000 Fr. mit der Installation.
Das Gerät kostet 800'000 Fr.
Und das dient
einem direkten Patientennutzen.
Es beruhigt,
man kann besser arbeiten.
Mit dem Nutzen, den der Patient hat,
ist es in einer Woche amortisiert.
Basel an einem frühen Herbstmorgen.
Im Unispital beginnt ein Marathon -
für ein Spezialistenteam ...
... und für Jeannette Petrusch.
Guten Morgen.
Kein Luxuszimmer, keine Parkettböden.
Sie braucht
ein hoch spezialisiertes Team.
Eine Infektion in der Hüfte macht
die Operation noch komplizierter.
Gut geschlafen?
- Relativ gut geschlafen.
Wunderbar. Heute geht es
in den Operationssaal.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Dinge, die besprochen werden müssen?
Eigentlich ist es klar.
Ich bin gut informiert worden ...
- Wunderbar.
... gestern von Ihnen beiden.
- Gut.
Wir machen heute den ersten Schritt:
den Ausbau der infizierten Prothese.
- Mhm.
Wir schauen, ob die Bakterien
die gleichen geblieben sind
wie bei der Voruntersuchung
und werden sie behandeln.
Da sind wir wieder
als ganzes Team für Sie da.
Wenn es so bleibt, werden wir in ca.
acht Wochen den Wiedereinbau machen
und den ganzen Spuk für Sie
hoffentlich beenden können.
Ich hoffe,
dass das Ganze jetzt gut wird.
Bis später.
- Bis später. Adieu miteinander.
Heute ist Jeannette Petruschs
zehnte Hüftoperation.
Eine komplexe Revisionschirurgie,
die in der Schweiz nur wenige
Spezialistenteams durchführen.
Wenn es heute nicht funktioniert,
wird ihre Hüfte wohl nie mehr gut.
Das macht ihr Angst.
Bis die Narkose eingeleitet wird ...
Und dann muss ich daliegen
und einatmen,
an etwas Schönes denken.
Es wird gut.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Einfach das Ganze und, und ...
Ich denke an meine Tochter.
Ich denke an liebe Menschen.
Die machen sich jetzt auch Gedanken.
Wie ich das überstehen werde.
Alle drücken mir fest die Daumen,
dass es gut wird und ich nicht mehr
so starke Schmerzen habe
und nicht mehr so leiden muss.
Hat Jeannette Petrusch
einfach Pech gehabt?
Hätte sie weniger leiden müssen,
wenn sie damals
ein anderes Spital gewählt hätte?
Komplikationen kann es immer geben.
Kein Operationsteam ist fehlerfrei.
Die Anzahl Fehler
kann allerdings unterschiedlich sein.
Und nicht alle Teams reagieren gleich
gut, wenn Schwierigkeiten auftauchen.
Grosse Spitäler seien da im Vorteil,
gerade bei komplexen Problemen.
Ich habe hier im Haus
die Möglichkeit,
für jede Fragestellung
Spezialisten hinzuzuziehen.
Ich kann einen Gefässchirurgen,
einen Beckentraumatologen beiziehen.
Ich kann die Spezialisten
aus den Organteams hinzuziehen
und mit denen operieren, wenn ich
denke, dass ich Hilfe brauche.
Das machen wir regelmässig.
Schnitt.
* Leises Piepen *
Scheisse.
Die Prothese scheint schon länger
nicht mehr stabil gewesen zu sein.
Oh my God!
Da steht ja nichts mehr.
Das ist das Stück,
das aus der Prothese gebrochen ist.
Der knöcherne Defekt ist am Schaft
grösser, als ich erwartet habe.
Um Gottes willen.
Herr Clauss,
wie sieht es im Gelenk aus?
Also ...
Wesentlich schlechter als erwartet.
Von der knöchernen Struktur
am Oberschenkel
hat sich durch den Infekt
relativ viel weggefressen.
Das ist eine Herausforderung.
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Bitte.
Hohe Konzentration
bei Chirurg Martin Clauss.
Musik hilft ihm, sich zu fokussieren.
* Leichte Musik *
Scheissdreck.
Im Moment bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Der Defekt im Oberschenkelknochen
war schon vorher
und viel grösser als erwartet.
Das wird rekonstruierbar sein.
Die Frage ist,
wie die Funktion sein wird.
Ob sie genügend Kraft hat,
um die Hüfte zu stabilisieren
und nicht hinkt, wenn sie geht.
Die Operation war selbst für den
erfahrenen Chirurgen und sein Team
eine grosse Herausforderung.
Knapp 2 1/2 Std. Schwerarbeit.
* Leichte Popmusik im Hintergrund *
* Stöhnen *
Das war lediglich
die erste Operation.
Wenn alles gut läuft,
kommt in zwei Monaten die zweite.
* Schweres Ausatmen *
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Jeannette Petrusch kämpft schwer
mit den Folgen der Infektion.
Infektionen gehören zu den häufigsten
Komplikationen bei Operationen.
Im Durchschnitt gibt es bei
rund einer von 100 Hüftoperationen
eine Infektion.
Komplikationen lassen sich
nicht immer vermeiden.
Es gibt jedoch Faktoren,
die das Risiko verringern können.
Einer davon: hohe Fallzahlen.
Die Fallzahlen sind in den Spitälern
sehr unterschiedlich.
Es gibt Spitäler,
die selten Hüftimplantate einsetzen.
Einige kommen
auf weniger als 50 Fälle.
Diese Mindestfallzahl
verlangt z.B. der Kanton Zürich.
Die meisten Spitäler
haben höhere Fallzahlen.
Höhere Fallzahlen, bessere Qualität.
Das ist zwar nicht immer garantiert.
Aber internationale Studien zeigen,
dass sich ab einer Fallzahl von 250
das Risiko für Komplikationen
stark reduziert.
Drei Viertel der Schweizer Spitäler
haben tiefere Fallzahlen.
Es wird häufig verkürzt -
sozusagen auf das Bild:
Der Chirurg braucht viel
handwerkliche Erfahrung.
Das spielt sicher auch eine Rolle.
Aber was wir vergessen: Alles drum
herum braucht auch viel Erfahrung.
Eine Pflegefachfrau z.B.
hat Erfahrungswerte,
wenn sie viele Patienten nach
einem bestimmten Eingriff sieht.
Sie hat Erfahrungswerte:
Wie entwickelt sich ein Patient
nach der Operation?
Dann sieht sie auch schneller, wenn
sich etwas nicht gut entwickelt.
Die Pflegefachleute drum herum
sind Experten.
Die Physiotherapeuten sind Experten.
Die Intensivstationen haben solche
Patienten oft in Betreuung, usw.
Natürlich ist es
die chirurgische Qualität.
Aber da ist auch
das ganze Drumherum,
und das spielt eine grosse Rolle.
Im Kantonsspital Nidwalden ist
die Stunde der Operation gekommen.
Antoinette Huser
erhält ein neues Hüftgelenk.
Sie hofft,
dass sie endlich wieder einfacher
und mit weniger Schmerzen
durch den Alltag kommt.
Jetzt gilt es ernst.
- Sie müssen keine Angst haben.
Nein, nein.
- Es wird alles gutgehen.
Alles gut.
Bei den meisten Hüftoperationen
läuft alles gut.
Aber bei jeder 40.
gibt es ein Problem,
das eine zweite Operation
nötig macht.
Das zeigen neue Schweizer Zahlen.
Frau Huser?
* Regelmässiges Piepen *
Es ist eine Routineoperation.
Aber es ist sicherlich
eine Operation,
die zu den grösseren
der Orthopädie gehört.
Es braucht schon
eine gewisse Erfahrung dazu.
Schnitt.
- Ja.
Das Spital Nidwalden
will eine gute medizinische Qualität.
Deshalb operieren
die Chirurginnen und Chirurgen
jeweils nur ein
oder zwei verschiedene Gelenke.
Bei Alexander Kerber
sind es Hüfte und Knie.
So sollen Fallzahlen und
Behandlungsqualität erhöht werden.
Früher war das
in vielen Spitälern anders.
Chirurgen waren Generalisten.
Sie operierten oft viele Gelenke und
hatten bei manchen tiefe Fallzahlen.
Gut, ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Wir haben alles wie geplant gemacht.
Von der Prothesengrösse,
der Länge usw.
Die Patientin
hat wenig Blut verloren.
Wir sind zügig vorangekommen.
Es lief so wie erwartet.
* Wiederholtes Piepen *
Die Operation ist vorbei.
Haben Sie schön geträumt?
Waren Sie am Meer,
wie abgesprochen?
* Regelmässiges Piepen *
Alles vorbei.
- Alles vorbei, ist gut gegangen.
Ah.
Das Spital in Stans
will die Qualität sichern.
Aber es will auch Patientinnen und
Patienten - also Kunden Ð anlocken,
um genügend Einnahmen zu generieren.
Einem unrentablen Spital
droht heutzutage die Schliessung.
Deshalb will Spitaldirektor
Urs Baumberger
auch unkonventionelle Wünsche
erfüllen -
v.a. für Zusatzversicherte
und Privatpatienten.
All unsere Suiten tragen
einen Namen aus der Umgebung.
Die Suite Rigi ist nicht Zimmer 402,
das ist das Individuelle daran.
Der Patient kann sagen,
er sei in der Rigi.
Es sollte keiner drin sein.
Das ist eine Businesssuite.
Warum eine Businesssuite?
Ich erwähnte,
dass ich oft Patienten besuche.
Unter ihnen waren Patienten,
Businessleute, die hier arbeiteten.
Ob sinnvoll oder nicht,
das sei dahingestellt.
Eine Businesssuite hat einen PC.
Sie hat, ähnlich wie zu Hause,
einen Drucker, Scanner.
Man hat einen Stehtisch
und kann mit dem Stick oder dem PC
eine PowerPoint-Präsentation
anschauen.
Damit sind die Wünsche abgedeckt.
Und das Bad ist so angeordnet,
dass man während des Zähneputzens
rausschauen kann.
Braucht es solche Suiten?
Das Gesundheitssystem
wird immer teurer,
und dann haben Sie so grosse Suiten.
Wenn wir Zusatzversicherte haben ...
Im ambulanten Bereich haben wir
ein Minus von ca. 3 Mio. Fr.
Er ist schweizweit
nur 80 % kostendeckend.
Im stationären, mit der Vergütung
der Patienten mit Grundversicherung,
haben wir auch ein Minus.
Mit den Halbprivaten und Privaten
verdient man das Geld.
Davon profitieren wiederum alle.
Die Gelder
kommen von Privatpatienten,
sie helfen, uns zu subventionieren.
Wir brauchen dazu
keine Kassen- oder Steuergelder.
Der Grundversicherte
kann in die Hände klatschen.
Je mehr Zusatzversicherte,
desto mehr profitiert er.
Wenn man die will,
muss man etwas bieten.
Die Strategie funktioniert.
Stans war jahrelang
finanziell erfolgreich.
Nicht selbstverständlich
für ein Spital in der Schweiz.
Doch das Jahr 2020
ist ausserordentlich.
Corona-Welle, Shutdown.
Anfang April.
Sitzung des Corona-Führungstabs
im Kantonsspital Nidwalden.
Wie in anderen Spitälern
muss umgeplant werden.
In der ersten Welle dürfen nur noch
dringend notwendige Eingriffe
durchgeführt werden.
Sie müssen Kapazitäten freihalten für
Corona-Patientinnen und -Patienten.
Damit fehlten die anderen Patienten.
Die Fixkosten haben wir. Den Betrieb
haben wir runtergefahren.
Personal schicken wir nach Hause,
weil es weniger Sprechstunden gibt.
Die Hälfte operiert.
Es tut weh, wenn man die letzten
Jahre wirtschaftlich gearbeitet hat
und jetzt - in diesem Jahr -
sehr viel Geld vernichtet,
wenn ich das so sagen darf.
Irgendwer muss dann ja bezahlen.
Dieser Irgendwer ist der Staat
oder die Krankenkasse.
Das ist der Bürger -
und das tut mir weh.
Hier führte die erste Welle zu
einer Ertragseinbusse von 4 Mio. Fr.
Bei anderen Spitälern war es mehr.
Das Kantonsspital Nidwalden
konnte einen Teil wieder aufholen -
etwa mit mehr Operationen
nach der ersten Welle
sowie der Pflege von
COVID-Patientinnen und ÐPatienten.
Das ist aufwendig, auch wenn sie
nicht auf der Intensivstation sind.
Guten Morgen. Wie geht es?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ich hoffe,
ich bin auf der Zielgeraden.
Aber es ist noch ein Weg
bis dorthin. - (Pflegerin) Genau.
Ritchie Mathis war einer der ersten
COVID-Patienten der Deutschschweiz.
Plötzlich hat man es selbst.
Wenn man sieht, was in Europa
alles abgegangen ist,
macht man sich schon Gedanken.
Auf welchem Level ist man?
Hat man eine Chance, oder ...
Wie entwickelt sich
die ganze Geschichte?
Das ist keine angenehme Situation.
Es gibt nur eines:
hoffen, dass es gut kommt.
* Er atmet schwer aus. *
Rund zwei Wochen
war Ritchie Mathis im Frühling 2020
wegen Corona im Spital.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ende April 2020.
Ritchie Mathis konnte
mittlerweile das Spital verlassen.
Corona hat Spuren hinterlassen,
im Körper - und in der Psyche.
Es wird einem eher bewusst,
wie schnell es kippen kann auf ...
* Er räuspert sich. *
... der gesundheitlichen Seite.
Das ist wahnsinnig.
Heute ist heute,
und morgen sieht es ganz anders aus.
Ein Aufenthalt im Spital
ist eine Ausnahmesituation -
gerade, wenn man schwer krank ist.
Ich habe noch nie
so etwas Schlimmes erlebt.
Es ist auf eine Art ...
Man will Luft holen
und bekommt keine.
Von der Umgebung her ...
Man ringt immer mehr nach Luft.
Man hat das Gefühl, man ersticke.
Kein zweites Mal,
wenn das möglich ist.
Hatten Sie Angst?
- Ja.
Dann kommen
die inneren, mentalen Dinge,
die plötzlich zu spielen beginnen.
Man ist im Spital
und hat ausser dem Telefon
keinen Kontakt zur Aussenwelt.
Man hat keine Energie mehr.
Dann fängt man irgendwann an,
nachzudenken.
Da kommen gewisse Ängste auf
und man denkt,
es wäre manchmal gut,
wenn man mit jemandem reden könnte.
Im Spital ist ein solcher Austausch
nicht möglich.
Vielen Menschen geht es im Spital
wie Ritchie Mathis.
Sie fühlen sich allein
und ausgeliefert.
Sie haben Fragen und Ängste.
Das nehmen Spitäler verstärkt auf.
Ärztinnen und Ärzte sind immer
weniger Götter in Weiss.
Sie werden
zu kundenorientierten Dienstleistern.
Wir müssen konsequent,
beinahe schon brutal,
auf unseren Kunden, den Patienten
und den Zuweiser ausgerichtet sein.
Alle Mitarbeiter -
ob mit oder ohne Patientenkontakt -
müssen die Ängste und die Situation,
in der die Patienten sind,
aufnehmen, aufsaugen können.
Diese empathische Kommunikation
ist für viele Spitäler neu.
Das Spital Nidwalden
hat sich deshalb
Hilfe aus einer anderen Branche
geholt und sich gefragt:
Wer pflegt Kundenorientierung
schon seit Langem?
Reifen, Felgen sind gut.
Das Reifenprofil ist noch gut.
René Filliger
ist Kommunikationsexperte.
Seine Heimat
ist die Automobilbranche.
Er schult Serviceleute
sowie Verkäuferinnen und Verkäufer.
Er sagte es zwar, aber ich konnte
mir nichts darunter vorstellen.
Das bedeutet,
ich habe kein richtiges Interesse.
So etwas zu verkaufen
wird schwierig.
Nun hat er ein zweites Standbein:
das Kantonsspital Nidwalden.
Hier schult er Ärzte
und Pflegefachleute.
Ist das eine gute Idee,
dass ein Autoverkaufsberater
medizinisches Personal trainiert?
Im Spital geht es um Gesundheit -
nicht um Reifen und Felgen.
Im Kommunikationsbereich
kann man sehr vieles vergleichen.
Gehen wir von der Zielsetzung aus:
Grundsätzlich ist das oberste Ziel,
sei es bei einem Patienten-
oder Verkaufsgespräch,
dass man Vertrauen aufbauen kann.
Dazu braucht es -
sei es im Autosektor
oder im Gesundheitswesen -
viel gute Kommunikation, um das
Vertrauen des Kunden zu gewinnen.
Eloquent, sehr belesen.
- Genau.
Sportlich.
- Ja.
Die Teilnehmenden
kreieren fiktive Patiententypen
und versuchen herauszufinden,
welche Bedürfnisse sie haben.
Er kommt von seiner Alp runter.
(Frau) Er ist pensioniert und
möchte möglichst schnell nach Hause.
René Filliger weiss,
wovon er spricht.
In Stans begleitet er
regelmässig Patienten.
Ich nenne euch ein Beispiel,
das ich selbst erlebt habe.
Ich durfte eine Patientin,
eine 80-jährige Nidwaldner Dame ...
Es ging um eine Hüftoperation.
Ich begleitete die Frau
in einem solchen Gespräch.
Der Orthopäde erklärte alles -
mit Bildern, mit Schnittbildern.
Er zeigte alles:
Da würden wir es so machen,
so würde es dann aussehen.
Er sagte auch, wo er den Bohrkanal
setzt und wo genau er durchgeht.
Plötzlich sagte die Dame neben mir:
"Herr Doktor, wenn Sie noch mehr
erzählen, kippe ich vom Stuhl."
Für den einen Patienten ist die
detaillierte Geschichte interessant,
aber ein anderer Patient
kann völlig überfordert sein.
Diese Individualität
müssen wir den Patienten bieten.
Ist das okay? Gut.
Für mich
ist es eine Qualitätssteigerung,
weil der Patient
das Gesamtpaket beurteilt.
Seine Wahrnehmung
zählt ab dem ersten Moment.
Vielleicht kommt er
nervös an den Empfang,
weil ihm eine Operation bevorsteht.
Bis er das Spital verlässt,
hat er viele Kontakt-
und Kommunikationspunkte.
Wenn das Gesamtpaket stimmt,
ist auch die Grundhaltung gut.
Er verteilt sicher einen
höheren Score, wenn man ihn fragt,
wie der Aufenthalt und die
medizinischen Leistungen waren.
Das Wichtigste für uns:
Wir haben eine gute Referenz.
Er erzählt das weiter.
So können wir sicher sein,
dass wir genügend Patienten haben.
Auch für die Patientensicherheit ist
Kommunikation ein wichtiges Thema.
Denn: Eine gute Kommunikationskultur
könne Fehler verhindern.
Patienten sollen sich mitteilen,
Ärztinnen lernen zuzuhören.
Es gibt sehr viele Untersuchungen
darüber, die zeigen,
dass, wenn es zu einem Fehler,
einer Medikamenten- oder
Patientenverwechslung gekommen ist,
die Patienten schon vorher das Ge-
fühl hatten, irgendwas sei komisch.
Und genauso,
wie man viel fragen soll,
soll man auch
viele Informationen geben.
Wenn man Erfahrungen
mit einem Medikament hat,
ob gut oder nicht gut,
dann kann man das sagen:
"Das habe ich schon einmal bekommen.
Das ging nicht gut für mich."
Man fühlt sich doch aktiver, wenn
man beteiligt ist an der Behandlung,
als wenn man Dinge einfach
mit sich passieren lassen muss.
Kantonsspital Nidwalden.
Zurück zu Hüftpatientin
Antoinette Huser.
Und jetzt? Drehen?
Bald umdrehen, dann schauen wir ...
Antoinette Huser geht es
zwei Tage nach der Hüftoperation
bereits sehr gut.
Ein Verlauf wie aus dem Lehrbuch.
... zwischen den beiden Gehstöcken.
Dann dürfen Sie wieder geradeaus.
Achtung.
- Ha.
Ihr Ehemann kommt zu Besuch.
Seit 50 Jahren haben sie praktisch
jeden Tag miteinander verbracht.
Freuen Sie sich, Ihre Frau zu sehen?
- Und wie!
Ja, doch.
Sie fehlt mir schon.
Und v.a. auch dem Hund.
* Er summt. *
# Ti, ri, ri ...
Ja, salü, salü! Liebe Antoinette!
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut, wie du siehst.
Du hast kalte Hände.
Schau, da.
Das ist wirklich schön.
- Gut gemacht.- Ja, ja.
Die Operation ist geschafft.
Nun wartet zu Hause
die nächste Herausforderung.
Sicher sechs Wochen mit den Stöcken.
Dann musst du mir
halt ein wenig helfen.
Z.B. die Socken anziehen und so.
Ah ja?
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe noch nie
einer Frau Socken angezogen.
Ich möchte mir Mühe geben und ihr
zu Hause möglichst gut beistehen.
Man kann mich
schon etwas einspannen. Ja, ja.
Die Generation Männer,
zu denen mein Mann gehört,
konnte früher zu Hause
nichts machen.
Ja, zumindest du nicht.
Ja ...
- Zu Hause.
Das war so.
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe ihn schon so übernommen,
als wir geheiratet haben.
Gut.
Mein Bein ist etwas eingeschlafen.
Tschau.
Tschau.- Alles, alles Gute.
- Mach's gut.
Tschau, tschau. Mach's gut.
Ja, tschüss.
Unispital Basel.
Vor zwei Monaten wurde hier Jeannette
Petrusch ein erstes Mal operiert.
Guten Tag.
* Sie lacht. *
Sehen wir uns wieder.
- Ja.
Wie ist es Ihnen ergangen?
- Also ...
Recht schlecht. Am Anfang
war es sehr mühselig.- Ja.
Jeannette Petrusch brauchte lange,
um sich von der Operation zu erholen.
Es war ein grosser Eingriff -
und nur die erste Etappe.
In wenigen Tagen
folgt die zweite grosse Operation.
Am Ende soll es eine gute Hüfte
für Sie werden
und hoffentlich die letzte Operation
für die nächsten 20 Jahre.
Man muss einfach abwarten.
Wir müssen am Montag
die Operation hinter uns bringen.
Wir sind gut vorbereitet. Es wird
ein grosses Team vorhanden sein.
Zum Behandlungsteam gehört
Infektiologie-Professor Parham Sendi.
Denn Jeannette Petrusch hatte
nicht nur ein orthopädisches Problem.
Wir sind mit grosser
Wahrscheinlichkeit überzeugt,
dass der Infekt weg ist.
Aber Vertrauen ist gut,
Kontrolle ist besser.
Darum braucht sie weiterhin ein Team,
das sich um sie kümmert.
Jeannette Petrusch
ist ein spezieller Fall.
Aber es gibt viele Menschen
mit ähnlichen Problemen.
Es sind Komplikationen,
die jeder Einzelne selten ...
Jeder Operateur
hat sie Gott sei Dank selten.
Die Behandlung
ist aber aufwendig und kompliziert.
Durch die Bündelung der Patienten
hier am Unispital
können wir über grosse Stückzahlen
andere Qualitätsstandards erzielen,
als wenn es jeder einzeln macht.
Es braucht Vertrauen
und ein Miteinander.
Die Ärzteschaft
muss miteinander reden,
damit man solche Patienten zuweist.
Spezialisierung und hohe Fallzahlen
sind auch eine Folge des Wettbewerbs.
Der Wettbewerb
führt nicht nur zu Konkurrenz,
sondern auch zu Zusammenarbeit.
Urs Baumberger,
Direktor vom Spital Nidwalden,
hat sich ein grosses Partnerspital
gesucht: das Kantonsspital Luzern.
2021 werden die beiden
Kantonsspitäler zusammengelegt.
Stans
ist kein eigenständiges Spital mehr.
Es gibt gewisse Herausforderungen,
grosse Sachen wie der Kostendruck,
der wirklich aktuell ist,
dazu die Ambulantisierung,
die Spezialisierung, die Mindest-
fallzahlen, der Fachkräftemangel,
die Digitalisierung.
Das geht nur gemeinsam.
Sali, Gabi. Wie begrüssen wir uns?
* Lachen *
Nur im Verbund sieht Baumberger
eine Überlebenschance
für kleinere Spitäler.
Ein Projekt dieser Zusammenarbeit ist
ein Hightech-Tumorzentrum in Luzern
mit modernster Strahlentherapie -
in Betrieb seit Frühling 2020.
Vom Zusammenschluss profitiere der
grosse, aber auch der kleine Partner.
Wir machen ja nur das, was wir
können, das ist abgesprochen.
Was wir nicht können,
geben wir weiter. Das ist wichtig.
Steht man allein unter Kostendruck,
versucht man,
alles bei sich zu behalten,
um die Volumen zu bekommen.
Dann macht man Dinge,
die man besser nicht sollte.
Innerhalb einer Familie geben wir
das dem Bruder, der es besser kann.
* Lachen *
Danke. Tschüss. Mach's gut. Merci.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Geht es im Wettkampf der Spitäler
genügend um Qualität?
Oder stehen Marketing und Interessen
des Spitals im Vordergrund?
Verbessert der Wettbewerb
der Spitäler die Lage der Patienten?
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ich bin wirklich nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, dass der Wettbewerb
häufig über Dimensionen stattfindet,
die für Patienten und für Fragen
der Qualität und Sicherheit
nicht relevant sind.
Es geht dann genau
um irgendwelche Daten,
die für viele Patienten
gar nicht zutreffen.
Viele Spitäler zeigen sich
nicht sehr transparent darin,
was sie wirklich
für die Sicherheit machen.
Das wird wenig dargestellt
und aktiv bewirtschaftet.
Mir wäre es lieber,
die Leistungserbringer
würden mehr kooperieren,
als im Wettbewerb
miteinander zu stehen.
Schlussendlich
bin ich überzeugt davon,
dass sich gute Qualität durchsetzt.
Wenn man regelmässig gute
und verlässlich gute Qualität
für die Patienten abliefert,
gibt es auch weitere Zuweisungen.
Ich glaube, das wird sich
am Ende durchsetzen.
Es geht nicht darum,
ob man viel Werbung macht,
davon halte ich nichts.
Es braucht gute Qualität, die man
auch dokumentieren und belegen kann.
Früher Morgen kurz vor Weihnachten
im Unispital Basel.
Jeannette Petrusch
steht vor der zweiten Etappe
ihrer aufwendigen Hüftrevision.
Läuft alles gut, beendet diese Opera-
tion einen jahrelangen Leidensweg.
Ein Leidensweg,
den es u.a. deshalb gibt,
weil bei einer früheren Operation
in einem anderen Spital
falsche Implantatteile
verwendet wurden.
Fälle wie dieser
haben dazu beigetragen,
dass die Schweiz ein nationales
Implantateregister einführte,
um die Patientensicherheit
zu erhöhen.
Das Register hat den Vorteil,
dass man später
die Informationen rausziehen kann.
Bei Frau Petrusch gab es
keine alten Operationsberichte mehr.
Die Dokumentationspflicht
des Voroperateurs war abgelaufen.
Deshalb konnten die Kollegen, die
die letzte Revision gemacht haben,
nur bedingt auf das Implantat
und die Spezialitäten zugreifen.
Das erklärt die Komplikation,
auch wenn sie immer ärgerlich ist.
Das geschieht mit einem Register
künftig weniger?
Ich hoffe, es ist einer der Effekte,
die wir damit erzielen.
In den nächsten knapp 3 Std.
setzt Operateur Martin Clauss
die neue, extra für Jeannette
Petrusch fabrizierte Prothese ein.
Tisch ein bisschen hoch.
Schnitt.
Blöde Ecke, um blind reinzubeissen.
Das grosse Ding muss da jetzt rein.
Das ist jetzt das Hauptproblem.
So weit waren wir noch nie.
Jetzt sitzt es.
Jetzt sitzt es zur Probe.
Sitzt es richtig, wackelt es nicht.
Der Patient wackelt,
wenn man am Implantat wackelt.
Das ist das definitive Implantat.
Es hat sich gut angehört.
Jetzt rütteln.
Ah, geh doch rein.
Yes.
* Er ächzt. *
Es fehlt nicht mehr viel.
Danke.
* Tiefes Ausatmen *
* Aufstöhnen *
So.
Fertig.
Wie ist es gelaufen?
- Sehr gut.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit dem Endergebnis.
Jetzt muss es verheilen.
V.a. der Schaft muss einheilen.
Wir werden sie sechs Wochen
teilbelasten lassen.
Wir müssen schauen,
dass der Infekt wirklich weg ist.
Wir hoffen, dass es für lange Zeit
die letzte Hüftoperation war.
Frau Petrusch, guten Tag.
Die Operation ist gut gelaufen.
Sie sind am Wachwerden.
Beromünster. Drei Monate nach der
Hüftoperation von Antoinette Huser.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen,
es geht wunderbar.
Ich habe noch ein Problem,
wenn ich beginne, zu gehen.
Das muss ich noch trainieren.
Die Muskeln wurden
bei der Operation gedehnt.
Dazu gehe ich zur Therapie.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Ich denke, wir beginnen gleich
mit der anstrengendsten Übung.
Das ist die Königsklasse
der Hüftübung.
Die Knie entfernen sich
voneinander, aber das Becken bleibt.
Boah.
- Okay. Zurück, Antoinette.
Puh, das ist anstrengend.
Noch neunmal.
- Okay.
Der Reha-Prozess läuft nach Plan. Das
kommt allerdings nicht von alleine.
Okay. Kurze Pause.
Man muss konsequent sein
und dranbleiben.
Es ist ja in meinem Interesse,
dass ich schnellstmöglich
wieder fit bin.
Schuhe binden
könnte ich jetzt wieder.
Das konnte ich auch nicht mehr.
Ich konnte nicht mehr so runter.
Tschüss zusammen.
Ich bin froh,
die Operation gemacht zu haben.
Ich sehe erst jetzt,
dass ich es früher
hätte machen sollen.
Die letzten drei Monate
vor der Operation
hatte ich immer Schmerzen.
Ich wollte es irgendwie nicht
wahrhaben, dass ich es machen muss.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Reinach, Februar 2021.
Bald beginnt ein neuer Abschnitt
für Jeannette Petrusch.
Bald, ja.
Wenn es ohne Stöcke geht,
fängt das Leben
eigentlich wieder richtig an.
Sie hat zwei aufwendige
Revisionsoperationen hinter sich.
Der Infekt ist weg.
Und die Schmerzen praktisch auch.
Es ist für mich wie Tag und Nacht.
Es war ein langer Weg bis hierhin,
wenn ich zurückdenke,
aber es hat sich gelohnt.
Die Hüfte
braucht noch Aufbautraining.
Und dann könnte wieder
viel möglich sein.
Vielleicht mal wieder Velo fahren,
im Frühling, Sommer.
Das wäre das Tollste.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2021